hay una noticia de hoy sobre cómo
algunos empleos
aseguran que algunos empleos fueron
creados del plan de estímulos y en
principio los números son impresionantes
la administración dijo que 650 mil
empleos fueron creados de 150 mil
millones de estímulos invertidos hasta
ahora así que déjenme escribirlo 650 mil
empleos
d
150 mil millones millones gastados ok
entonces de este dinero como lo
convertimos en una base de digamos por
trabajo déjenme sacar mi calculadora
aquí si gastamos 150 mil millones de
dólares para obtener 650 mil empleos
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es dividir
y dividir esta cantidad entre 650 mil
en 650.000 y eso obtenemos 230 mil
dólares por trabajo digamos más o menos
eso es igual a 230 mil dólares por
empleo que se asegura se han ahorrado
que se asegura que fueron ahorrados así
que obviamente no sólo se les pagó su
salario estas personas también estaban
agregando un valor para iniciar entonces
estos fueron muy buenos empleos 230 mil
dólares yo creo que es justo decir que
es mucho más de lo que la mayoría de
nosotros ganamos así que son muy buenos
empleos muy buenos empleos ahora también
hay otra cuestión al menos otros 350.000
empleos fueron creados de 189 mil
millones de deducciones fiscales así que
tuvimos 189 mil millones menos que el
gobierno pudo haber conseguido de
impuestos así que digamos estos son 350
mil empleos
de 189 mil millones
189 mil millones de dólares de deducción
de impuestos
de desgravación fiscal así que déjenme
ver cómo es esto en una base por trabajo
y vamos a hacer que la calculadora lo
haga tenemos 189 mil millones de dólares
ok y si eso ahora lo dividimos vamos
vamos ahora a dividirlo entre 350 mil
empleos ok entonces obtenemos 540 mil
dólares por empleo así que esto es igual
a 540 mil dólares por empleo
por empleo así que son mucho mejores que
los 230 mil dólares por empleo que
tuvimos ahorrando con 150.000 millones
así que claramente estos son personas
que les pagaron muy bien y que fueron
capaces de conservar sus empleos